you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
new york governor andrew cuomo resigned
this week and then immediately leaned in
for a goodbye kiss
that's right andrew cuomo resigned this
week amid sexual harassment allegations
and it's been a remarkable fall from
grace a year ago people were buying
merch with his face on it hell i even
got carried away and i bought a t-shirt
now what am i supposed to do with this
what am i going to do with this
what am i going to do with
this i know get mom written under it and
tell people you have an ugly mom oh
that's that's a good idea yeah thanks
for the first time in 20 years
scientists have discovered a new
carnivorous
carnivorous is a tough word yes but you
see it and you want to say coronavirus
yes
but it's it's carnivorous but you didn't
you said it and you won i did
i won't let carnivorous beat me no
i am it you are amber
could we go back
yeah i got to i forget what the setup
was for the first time in 20 years
scientists have discovered a new
carnivorous plant when asked for comment
scientists said help
help us
pepsi announced that they are partnering
with the makers of sam adams beer to
create an alcoholic version of mountain
dew it's called mountain dui
i love to act like that would be gross
but yeah i would drink the butt off
i'm sorry i sent you a photo of that
yeah on twitter and you said rewrote
back this is how i die
i did
and it is it's been a wild ride
mattel has created a barbie doll of the
female scientist who helped develop the
oxford astrazeneca coronavirus vaccine
they also made a ken doll of the male
scientist who tried to take credit for
it
you guys are quite vocal yeah
isn't it so weird lovely i mean
every little thing you do i love so bad
yeah yeah
bang is nice i gotta be honest it's like
i'm looking at a sea of ninjas
like everyone's got a mask on everyone's
a different version of uh scorpion yes
get over here no i can't we have to
socially distance guys
now if you understood that uh mortal
kombat reference please tweet at tarik
tarik you a nerd yeah
hey even though i'm the one you made the
according to forbes singer and
businesswoman rihanna is the world's
wealthiest female musician that story
again y'all ain't never getting another
rihanna album
sorry
shoot she should just go live on a beach
or uh
i just hope it doesn't rain because if
it does she's gonna need uh
no one
hey
uh we cannot
legally clear that song so we'll sing it
in a different way yeah she needs to
prepare us all
[Applause]
you've heard of rihanna and umbrella
you're going to love
rihanna with her new hit parasol
we didn't sing the song we didn't sing
the song we didn't we are it's baby
steps over here yeah
the baltimore symphony orchestra last
week fired its principal flautist after
she allegedly shared coronavirus
conspiracy theories online it's the
first known instance of a flautist going
out on a low note
yeah
yeah and finally a dutch fashion
designer recently created a so-called
spider dress that uses sensors to help
wearers enforce social distancing i'll
take two said women who work for cuomo
and that was the monologue
did you guys like the monologue
i gotta all right i like it
it is very fun to have you guys yeah
it's really great it is so much fun it's
cool i'm excited so am i you guys we
covered a lot of news in that monologue
but
buckle up there's more okay republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green was
back in the news this week you may
remember that the last time we checked
in with marjorie taylor green she was
shouting at representative alexandra
ocasio-cortez
through the mail slot on her office door
look alexandria ocagio cortez i'm an
american citizen i pay your salary
through the taxes that you collect from
me through the irs you need to get rid
of your diaper and come out and be able
to talk to the american citizens instead
of having to use a flap
yikes
well last week a new video emerged of
taylor green
yelling telling a bunch of supporters at
a fundraiser what they should do if a
government volunteer comes to their door
to promote vaccines
and one more thing on that you lucky
people here in alabama might get a knock
on your door because i hear alabama
might be one of the most unvaccinated
states in the nation
well joe biden wants to come talk to you
guys
he's going to be sending one of his
police state friends uh to your front
door well what they don't know is in the
south we all love our second amendment
rights
and we're not real big on strangers
showing up on our front door are we
they might not like the welcome they get
wow
that is a lot of crazy hey amber
amber roofing oh crap what is it
marjorie taylor green is at the door
i'm back
[Music]
get rid of your diaper and come on out
and talk to me marjorie taylor green you
get away from my door why
it's my right as a taxpayer to shout at
you you pay taxes
not if i can help it
you are the worst get out of here well
if you want me to leave so bad why don't
you just send one of your police state
friends to come and make me
i don't have any police state friends
also wait are you pro-police or
anti-police
stop bullying me i'm not bullying you
yes you are asking follow-up questions
is the worst kind of bullying i'm gonna
call 9-1-1 but then the police state
will show up oh don't use your liberal
mind tricks on me
come out and play
no and you have got to get away from my
door oh oh i get it so you can come to
my door and force me to get a vaccine
but i can't come to your door and wave a
little pistol through the mail slot
oh no my gun
you cannot do that yes i can it's my
second amendment right oh ow quit
bumping me it's my turn
no it's not is there somebody else back
there with you
yes there is
hello amber it's me
handsome relatable bad boy next door
matt gates
no and handsome was the wrong word and i
i don't i don't want to talk to you
either
why not i'm just a wealthy successful
sociopath who's being investigated by
the police for several horrific crimes
you just described the plot of american
psycho
oh you have me at american baby
look amber we actually agree on a lot
more than we disagree on oh yeah like
what
whoa whoa
was that a follow-up question oh she
loves to do that bullying bullying
bullying
okay all right enough look you two don't
have anything better to do than harass
me at my job oh well
not really i got kicked off all my
committee assignments for being a freak
and all my closest friends are either in
custody or at sleepaway camp
so
yeah
this is pretty much all we have to do
today well as long as you're in the
building i heard they're giving away
free vaccines in the lobby whoa look at
the time
got around bye
i had a feeling that would work yeah
yeah you know it worked it did
she should be careful those things are
dangerous guns
no her nails
that's true yeah well speaking of
dangerous there's big news this week
about climate change in a recent study
who said that
who's there
it's me
it's my bonnet
oh hey bonnet
hey i put you on before bed last night
but when i woke up you were nowhere to
be found
that's cause i'm a mischievous little
rascal oh bonnet you're supposed to stay
on my head why should i no one likes
bonnets anymore in fact some people have
trouble with folks wearing bonnets out
in public
oh
bonnet
yep i think they're ashamed of us
because
we're bad
hey whoa bonnet you're not bad and yes
there have been a lot of people who say
black women should stop wearing bonnets
in public and now sometimes places won't
allow you in if you're wearing one but
don't you worry about that did you know
that it used to be illegal in a lot of
places for black people to leave their
house without their hair covered up
whoa
i feel like you're making that up i know
i wish i was but they were mad about us
not covering up our hair and now they're
mad that we are covering it up so we
can't win
why would people do such a thing well my
theory is hundreds of years ago they had
to dehumanize black people in order to
feel okay about enslaving us and a quick
way to do that is to think of us as
dirty and bad and a lot of us never want
to be looked at that way so we try extra
hard to make sure we and every black
person around us looks perfect but the
way we dress isn't the problem judging
black people based on your idea of how
they should look is called
respectability politics and that is the
problem but you don't hurt bonnet
yes
but it you don't hurt
you actually you help
i really help yeah whether it's making
sure my ends don't break or keeping my
sloppy bedtime hairstyle a secret i'll
never tell
you come in handy i do of course you do
i love you bonnie
[Music]
sometimes i have a tough time with my
hair
but he's always there for me it's my
bonnet
it's her bonnet
oh that's right
whenever i fall asleep
i know my style is gonna keep with me
and my bonnet
and her bonnet
[Music]
some people say they don't like the way
i wear it in the store
and yeah that used to make me feel so
sad but it doesn't anymore
cause if a sea in my bonnet makes you
sick
you can eat a big fat
because i love my body
[Applause]
that's right i do
if my bonnet were a baseball cap you
wouldn't have [ __ ] to say you're just
hating on my mind
on your bonnet
you know
black women ain't protected out there
now we can't even protect our hair come
on man it's just about it
i'm just a bonnet that's right you are
so
the next time you see a black woman
wearing a bonnet all on her own i want
you to reach inside swallow your pride
and leave her
alone
you should count yourself lucky you've
got to see her come down off her throne
just her and her bonnets
her and her bonnet
it's just me and my bonnet
me and my bunny
oh
i bought it i love you
i love you amber okay so bonnie the next
time anyone gives you any guff you oh oh
no he's gone
she wears her hair in four sloppy braids
at bedtime god damn it
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]